hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to be reviewing a
website by my caterer so I've been using
this dye for over five years for all the
events that I do with my business and
he's provided some awesome food and now
he's launching his own website and he
asked me to give a testimonial and also
wanted me to check it out and give him
any comments or suggestions so his name
is Seenu and let's go check out the site
so I came to Seenu after I was kind of
left in a lurch from another catering
company that last minute couldn't do
something for me and he filled in very
quickly and was responsive so that was
great in terms of what I look for when
looking for caterer the first thing is
obviously the food so it's great that
you're showing a variety of the food
that you offer here it could be maybe a
little bit more professionally designed
I don't know who would design but it's
pretty good you're leading in with the
pictures so it's good you know
appetizing stuff that makes people want
to learn a little bit more the next
thing is reliability there's a lot of
people who you know set up catering
companies that aren't reliable and and
leave their clients hanging like what
happened to me so especially for bigger
companies who are potentially hiring you
they want to make sure that you're
reliable you you know do everything on
time and so you know learn a little bit
more here this is your founded in the
year 2010 I might here want to share a
little bit more but what you do because
we've been using you for for over five
years and provided awesome service I
know you've been doing this for a lot
longer so I may not say that you were
just founded in the year 2010 and may
say something about all the experience
that you have as a chef because this
makes you seem really new and then you
know that may affect the reliability
factor for a lot of companies I say
you've asked I tell including private
public offices government organizations
colleges universities
that's great I maybe put some logos on
here to quickly show some of the clients
who have hired you and have found that
you have great service again a lot of
the companies are these little you know
one-man shows and they don't provide
great service and they don't deal with a
lot of big companies so that's who you
have to kind of separate yourself from
so it definitely puts some of the logos
in I see here you have a testimony from
somebody from Sun Life great you know
huge company put a Sun Life logo on here
and you know show that you you're
working with some of these big companies
so let's take a quick look around here
let's look in the about page so again
founded in 2010 now this is good so our
meals are prepared by Chef those over 20
years of experience our chef leads our
team our chef experience include be in
charge of kitchen so many well-known
fine-dining restaurants and private
catering companies so what I would do
here is say a little bit more about your
story so it's great you have 20 years
experience I think this should be on the
home page you know they don't even need
to show the year was founded just talk
about your 20 years of experience I show
a picture here of you so you get people
to know you the more personal you can
make your business the better so a big
smiling see new picture here would be
great I put your name in here as well
and I'd also you know if these are if
you've been in the chef of some
well-known fine-dining restaurants I'd
show the names so that you know people
can recognize that and you know again
will will make that make your company
seem more reputable and easier to get
them to want to contact you so it
definitely just fruits us spruce this up
a little bit it's great that you have it
but it add a little bit more to it click
on the menu people are obviously going
to go here see what you have to offer
I don't know why you have a menu and an
additional menu that's maybe a little
bit confusing for people but anyway you
have the menu what I try to do here is
really take a picture of everything if
possible so you have you have a picture
here because you have some more pictures
here it'd be great to see what you know
what a small platter looks like what a
medium flower looks like what a large
platter looks like this I found is one
of the hardest things to determine when
when ordering food I know we have a
relationship now where I just kind of
just tell you how many people and you
create something awesome but for new
clients it can be challenging the to
visualize what it is that you're going
to be presenting and how it looks so I
would definitely take a picture of each
of these so it's easier for clients to
understand and especially the ones you
don't have any pictures off here so you
know what is a breakfast sandwich plate
look like a breakfast platter I think
you're missing an R here so sandwich
platter probably so put it put a picture
of each of one each of these if you can
the next time we do it for clients just
take a small picture and pop it up on
the website and and fix this spelling
errors are are not great especially when
dealing with with bigger companies
because they again want to find somebody
who is reputable and reliable and
professional and having a spelling
mistake isn't doesn't look so good so I
definitely fix that up quickly you might
want to just run this whole thing
through a spellcheck to copy all the
pages into into word and give it another
quick look over to make sure that
everything is spelled properly if
there's one thing off there's probably a
couple that are off so going back up you
can order online great testimonials are
great so again here your testimonials
Centennial College that's good you put
mine here so this is great
I've worked with senator Cardin for five
years as a curator for my company they
are always reliable on time makes makes
great food and takes pride in his work I
couldn't imagine my event without
sandwich card so this is a little
strange because the there's a grammar
issues here so they're always reliable
on time this should be make great food
and take pride in their work
so I let's see what I actually wrote
here I've always seen it okay so I
talked about you which makes sense and
you changed it to your name which is
fine so I will just change this here to
make great food and take pride in their
work again you don't want to have
spelling grammar mistakes on your
website they might think that you know
either you wrote it down incorrectly or
that I don't know how to speak English
properly but either way it doesn't look
good for either of us here are guests on
this website so especially being the
second one up here again if somebody's
actually reading this and they see no
grammar mistakes then they may not think
it's as reputable a company so
definitely go through your whole site
make sure all the spelling and grammar
is correct before you're moving it to
the next step but overall pretty good
you know the pictures speak volumes they
look appetizing you know I want to eat
some of that Berkeley right now so
definitely a good job overall I mean the
design could be a little bit better I
see here it says powered by jj1 one IT
solutions in general you shouldn't have
this on your website unless they're
paying you or you worked out as out as
part of your deal you're promoting them
and linking back to their site and
they're probably not doing it for you so
I take that off unless you have some
kind of arrangement initially in place
to keep that on so I've seen to
hopefully that helped good luck with the
site for those of you who are watching
if you like the video please give it a
thumbs up below it makes me want to do
more of these free videos for you guys
and if you have a question about this
website or your website please leave a
comment below I always read those and
try to get back to each one so thank you
and we'll see you on the next episode
you